we're going to take you now to Saudi
Arabia where the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinking and his Saudi
counterpart faisabin farhana are holding
a news conference as the top U.S
Diplomat wraps up his three-day visit to
Saudi Arabia let's listen in
well
first of all um
foreign thank you thank you for your
hospitality uh thank you for bringing
all of our regional and Global Partners
together here in Riyadh
when President Biden traveled to Jeddah
Last Summer
he affirmed the importance of the Middle
East to the long-term security and
economic interests of the United States
and he made clear that we're committed
to continuing and deepening our
Partnerships in the region
together we can drive real progress for
all our people not only to address the
challenges or crises of the moment but
to chart an affirmative vision for our
shared future
over the last few days we have advanced
that progress on several fronts working
with our Saudi Partners working with the
gulf cooperation Council working today
with the global coalition to defeat Isis
the foreign minister and I just finished
a productive meeting of the global
coalition to counter Isis
the United States very much appreciates
the leadership of Saudi Arabia not only
in hosting this meeting but for its
contributions constant contributions and
crucial contributions day in day out to
our mission
while our Coalition has taken back the
territory that Isis once controlled and
inflicted severe losses on its
leadership Isis nonetheless remains an
active threat
the ministerial that we just had focused
on several key areas of need
those include
stabilizing areas liberated from Isis so
that the group can't exploit poor
security
economic or humanitarian conditions that
leave people desperate and also as
you've heard from the Prime Minister
repatriating foreign terrorist Fighters
and their families from out whole and
other displaced persons camps I was also
working to keep Pace with evolving
threats including isis's expanding
efforts across sub-Saharan Africa and
Isis coruscan our 86 member Coalition
leaves this ministerial better focused
and equipped to continue the mission to
eradicate Isis
the United States and Saudi Arabia both
as bilateral partners and through the
GCC are working closely together to
address several other challenges in the
region in Yemen when President Biden
took office war was raging the country
was experiencing arguably the worst
humanitarian crisis in the world
now we're working intensively with Saudi
Arabia and other partners to further
consolidate what has been a 14-month
long truce that we help to achieve
this was a central issue in my
discussions with the Saudi Crown Prince
and with the foreign minister and today
I had an opportunity as well to meet
with Yemen's president al-alimi to
discuss the path forward
our objectives our durable ceasefire and
an inclusive yemeni-led process mediated
by the U.N one that meets yemeni's calls
for justice for accountability for
redress for abuses and ultimately leads
to a political resolution of differences
in Yemen our special Envoy Tim lender
King will continue to work with the
parties and partners in the region in
the days and weeks they had to resolve
issues standing in the way of a lasting
peace
the United States of Saudi Arabia
together with the GCC are also focused
on Iran's destabilizing influence in the
region including its support for
terrorism and violent militia groups the
seizure of tankers transiting
international waters and nuclear
escalation
the United States continues to believe
that diplomacy backed by economic
pressure by deterrence and by strong
defense cooperation is the best way to
counter these dangerous actions
we support efforts by Saudi Arabia to
de-escalate tension and stabilize
relations
the United States and our Gulf partners
are working closely on the crisis in
Sudan
our two countries the United States and
Saudi Arabia have been leading an
intensive diplomatic campaign to get the
two sides to agree to and comply with
the ceasefire and to allow humanitarian
assistance to reach the people of Sudan
we will keep working toward a durable
cessation of hostilities and the Swift
formation of a civilian-led transitional
government together with our partners in
the Gulf in Africa and with the United
Nations
I also discussed with GCC Partners
increasing our joint efforts to combat
illicit synthetic drugs like captagon
which is having a devastating impact on
young people throughout this region just
as Fentanyl and other synthetic opioids
are doing the same in the United States
this partnership will be an important
part of our diplomacy to strengthen
Global cooperation on the growing
challenge posed by illicit synthetic
drugs
alongside by GCC and the Isis
engagements I also met with the
Ethiopian Deputy Prime Minister mcconan
to review the ongoing implementation of
the November 2 cessation of hostilities
agreement that agreement ended the
horrific crisis in Tigre
for peace to endure the parties must
acknowledge the atrocities committed and
pursue accountability together with
reconciliation
the United States will continue to
partner with Ethiopia as it builds a
credible transitional Justice process to
break the cycle of an ethic and
political violence that has gripped
Ethiopia and prevented it from reaching
its potential for far too long
the U.S partnership with Saudi Arabia
and the Gulf extends far beyond
addressing challenges and crises in the
region it is critical to expanding
opportunity and driving progress
for our people and for people around the
world
through the partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment the United
States and Saudi Arabia are working
together to deliver quality sustainable
infrastructure to benefit people in low
and middle income countries
for expanding digital connectivity
including by using new mobile
telecommunition telecommunition
technology like open cloud-based radio
access networks that are both secure and
affordable
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinking
speaking there alongside his Saudi
counterpart face out bin farahan after
his three-day visit to Riyadh which is
ending uh the two speaking about the
state of the relationship between the
two countries in other countries in the
region uh the U.S secretaries say saying
that the U.S partnership with Saudi
Arabia and Gulf countries is a stable
and strong one he says that both sides
the U.S and Saudi Arabia were working
together to address several challenges
in the region including the war in Yemen
he said they were working together to
consolidate the 14-month truth in Yemen
and are working on a permanent ceasefire
he also said they were working on the
crisis in Sudan together working towards
a durable cessation of hostilities there
and Anthony blinking adding that the usn
GCC countries were working together to
combat illicit drugs in the region like
captagon let's bring in our senior
political analyst Marwan bashara who is
joining us live from Paris Anthony
blinking outlining there some of the
issues and challenges the two sides of
the U.S the Saudi Arabia and other GCC
countries are working together on before
we get into the issues I just want to
ask you first about the state of this
relationship today between the U.S and
Saudi Arabia how strong is it how stable
is it
well clearly it is uh not as strong as
it was uh say five or six years ago it
has gone through some difficult phases
uh the last couple of years notably
under uh President Biden but also it
began to worsen under President Trump
when Saudi Arabia was attacked by Iran
and its proxies and Washington did not
step in to defend it as it were and so
Saudi Arabia has been uh you know quite
cold when it comes to relationship but
in the last several months there have
been several visits by American
officials including National Security
advisor including the CIA director and
now the Secretary of State all within
couple of months in order to try and
warn the relationships now whether they
whether they succeeded or not it really
remains to be sure clearly secretary
Lincoln is trying to put a good face on
it all quite complementary quite
positive underlining as you said or
outlining all the positive things that
they've reached I would be curious to
know what Mr Sullivan and Mr Burns
achieved when they were in Saudi Arabia
a CIA director National Security on very
important questions such as the big
disagreements in Syria the big
disagreements on China and on Iran and
so on
Americans right now in Saudi Arabia in a
very different landscape from what
they're used to I mean things have
considerably changed in the region with
their approachment the recent
approachment between Saudi Arabia and
Iran which was brokered by the Chinese
can they win back some of this influence
that they seem to have lost marijuana
you know it's it's really it's
conditional on how America could shift
its policies or how it can take better
command of its Assets in the region
because as you said it has been for the
last 30 years and it remains to be the
dominant foreign Force within the gulf
and within the Middle East at large
right but it certainly has been uh
Contracting it has been devolving its
influence has dissipated into a lot to a
large extent notably in countries like
Saudi Arabia where there has been you
know cooling of relationships now it
still has major assets in the region
especially in the Gulf in Qatar in
Kuwait in in the United Arab Emirates
Saudi Arabia and so on so forth but
China is increasing its influence within
the region so really for the time being
the United States is going to have more
than tactics in dealing with Saudi
Arabia more than you know on this issue
and that issue or trying to be appeasing
to the Crown Prince they need to come up
with a macro strategy that is serious if
President Biden as he said he's not
going to allow for a void to be felt by
China Russia and Iran well American is
to probably behave differently and
probably more Hands-On and yet so
he has been acting independently and
Saudi Arabia is not going to go back to
the days of pre-2019 or pre-2013 right
clearly Saudi Arabia like turkey want to
act
independently yeah and I was going to
ask you about the Saudis Marwan what
what is the Bedrock Foundation of
current Saudi foreign policy and how
does it fit with China and even current
U.S policy in the region
well look let's just start with the idea
that since the war in Ukraine started
it's expected that the main producing
countries of you know oil and gas would
have a surplus of 1.4 trillion dollars
so you can imagine that a kingdom like
Saudi Arabia and and clearly the the
idea of you know Carbon uh uh like
energies are are you know we're going to
have certain limited time in the future
with the clean energy stepping in so
they're trying to take advantage of what
they have now and of the leverage they
have on the oil and gas markets as it
were so we where we stand today fully is
that the United States since the Russian
invasion needs Saudi Arabia more than
Saudi Arabia needs the United States
this has especially been the case there
are several months because
Saudi Arabia cleverly intelligently
did normalize relationships with Iran
hence the danger from that side is no
longer so it did reduce tensions and
it's basically trying to solve the
problem in Yemen or the war in Yemen by
accommodating their their Nemesis the
houthis there so the Saudis don't need
Washington as much as Washington needs
today in order to reduce the oil prices
in order to build the Coalition against
Russia and so on so forth so in this as
a significant relationships
the Saudis have the advantage
and Americans need to act in a strategic
clever new way in order to recontain if
they must Saudi Arabia and other Gulf
Partners but this can have to start by
mutual respect any mutual interest not
treating them as dependent who they can
humiliate at will Marwan thank you very
much for your analysis as always Maron
bashara is our senior political analyst